my name is David Taylor and I'm an
assistant professor at the University of
Texas Austin today I'm going to talk to
you about the structure and function of
crisper cast surveillance complexes so
the outline for my talk today is to
first tell you a little bit about the
structure of a novel type for crisper
cast complex that hasn't been
characterized yet to date and then
second I'm going to talk to you about
the mechanisms of improved specificity
for some of the high fidelity cast 9
variants that exist today but first I
want to give a brief introduction to the
method that I use for most of my
research which is a single particle
cryo-electron microscopy so in single
particle cryo and what we do is we bring
an electron beam through the sample and
the particles are trapped in ice and so
the electron beam comes through the
sample it creates a projection image
that projection image is a noisy and it
has our particles trapped in all
orientations which lasts us so later
create that 3d structure but we have to
get rid of that noise first so in order
to get rid of the noise what we do is we
boxed out individual particle images
after boxing out those individual
particle images were able to classify
them into discrete groups usually based
on the projection view that the particle
exists in and so in this particular
example there's class 1 which represents
a side view of the particle and class 2
which represents the top view of this
particular particle and so once you've
done this alignment and classification
you can average particles within the
same class together and after you do
this averaging you get class averages
and these averages have increased signal
noise ratio and you can start to see
structural features especially secondary
structure features so those little rod
like densities which we call sausages or
alpha helixes and those particular class
averages and then through other image
reconstruction techniques finally were
able to get a 3d structure of the
complex and so this is a 3d structure of
a symmetrical object it doesn't
come out color-coded like that from the
reconstruction process we have to do
that later and that is time intensive
but also fun okay so the first thing I
want to talk about is structures of
CRISPR cast surveillance complexes and
so what does CRISPR cast so here's a
Nichola here's a electron micrograph of
an e coli cell being attacked by phages
and these pages are attaching to the U
coli cell and they're injecting their
viral genome into it with the idea of
infecting it actually the e.coli cell
and so one mechanism that bacteria have
come up with to fend off these phage
infections is CRISPR caste systems the
type of adaptive immunity and so how
does this work
on the first step there's the
immunization part or that genomic DNA
from the virus is cut into pieces and
integrated into the CRISPR Llosa in
between these invariant repeat sequences
and so later that repeat CRISPR low-side
is transcribed into a pre CRISPR in a
the pre CRISPR and is processed and to a
mature crispr RNA that mature crispr RNA
is then loaded into an effector complex
which we call Cascades and that CRISPR
any guides the effector complex to its
target so that it can cleave the target
or degrade it in another way and that's
an immunity stage of CRISPR caste
adaptive immunity okay so there's two
main classes of CRISPR castes complexes
there's class one which are the multi
subunit complex is typify by E coli is
type one II cascade there's also the
type two single subunit complex this is
where the CRISPR craze started these
single polypeptides have been repurposed
for various genome engineering
applications and have a lot of problems
for therapeutic applications what I'm
going to talk to you today about for
structure structure wise is a class one
complexes
and so it here's from actually an
outdated review article now but just
shows you kind of the breadth and depth
of the diversity these class won't
crisper cast systems so there's the type
one they can be divided up further in
the type 1 systems usually target DNA
and then there's the type 3 complexes
which target RNA they also target DNA
but for our purposes we'll say they're
targeting RNA and there's recently
identified type 4 complexes and so many
of these class 1 and CRISPR systems
remain to be characterized and so we're
going to focus today on these type 4
complexes which are really
uncharacterized and so this is a
collaboration between my laboratory and
the laboratories of right Jack's and
then Raymond stalls and some great
graduate students and postdocs that are
in their lab and a postdoc in my
laboratory Yi Joe so what we did is we
over expressed the proteins from a type
4 complex and I'm like oh bad bacterium
in e.coli and we pulled down using a tag
on one of the subunits after pulling
down we froze grids and we were able to
collect micrographs on our Titan krios
here at UT Austin and the circles yellow
circles show individual particles that
we were able to see in these motion
corrected micrographs and from those
micrographs we were able to collect we
were able to create reference free 2d
classes that show clear secondary
structure features in a warm like
particle and so after the 3d
reconstruction we were able to obtain a
structure at around 3.9 angstroms
resolution and you can see from the
structure as it's rotating that it has a
helical backbone of large subunits and
and crisper are me in the middle and
then a small filament that creates the
belly subunits that are different colors
of red to orange so we were able to
build an atomic model into that
reconstruction and here's what the model
looks like so you can see that the large
subunit or the CSF two subunits that are
gray and blue run on run and create this
helical backbone and there's the belly
subunits that create a smaller helical
backbone and these are the CSF for
proteins and then if you look at the
very right hand side you can see the
CRISPR and a snaking through the complex
okay so what can we glean from this
crystal structure well from this atomic
model so first is to look at the
backbone subunits so if you look at the
type 4 backbone subunit which is in gold
compared to a type 3 backbone subunit
you can see that they are almost super
imposable it has a rmsd of approximately
two angstroms you can see that it shares
those common palm domain and then this
thumb region at the top and so if you
were to take one of those backbone
subunits and place it on top of the
filament of the other complex you'd be
able to see how well the rest of them
overlay if you did it all things being
equal you didn't change anything else
and so if you do that you can see that
actually they overlay quite well so if
you if you use one for alignment they
all will kind of align to each other so
the backbone of the type 4 complex is
relatively conserved with that of the
type 3 complex from CMR okay and most
importantly if you look at this
conserved aspartate residue you'll see
that it is concerned
in its position roughly between both the
large subunits of the type 4 complex and
the type 3 complex and this residue has
been shown to be important for the
catalytic activity of the RNA cleaving
properties of this complex at least for
the type 3 and so that gives us some
hints and so the type 4 function and so
our hypothesis is that the type for
cascade Cleaves are in a similar lead to
a type 3 complex so on the right hand
side you could see a type 3 complex that
I solved as a postdoc at Berkeley with
Jennifer Doudna and in this particular
complex we have both the crispr RNA and
a target RNA bound to it and on the left
you'll see the type 4 complex again
looks very similar in this particular
complex but you don't have a target yet
but we think that it would target RNA
based on the thumb having the catalytic
residue that's similar to take 3 complex
which doesn't exist
in the type 1 Cascades ok so changing
directions a little bit talk about
functions of CRISPR Castiel's complexes
so I want to talk to you a little bit
about some cats 9 work that we've been
doing in the laboratory using kinetics
so again back to the two main classes so
we just talked about the class 1
complexes where they're multi subunit 2
very interesting biology but now we'll
talk about the class 2 single
polypeptide effector complexes this is a
collaboration between my laboratory and
Kim Johnson laboratory here at UT Austin
we've shared two great postdocs one's
Shang Tsung and you send Shang Zhou has
gone on to an industry position you sent
a cell here finishing up this work and
then a laboratory manager Helen Shannon
my laboratory and KJ and undergraduate
in my laboratory
so it's a very productive collaboration
between kinetic system structural
biologists so what we've shown earlier
is that our loop formation is the rate
step four wild-type Cassadine which
we'll call SP cast nine so upon initial
binding of the DNA by cast nine there's
our loop formation which means that the
targa strand is base bearing with the
CRISPR na the non target strand is being
looped out away from the rest of the
complex and so that will be targeted by
the Rosi domain while the target channel
will be targeted by the h and h domain
and so we showed that DNA and winding is
relatively slow one per second come as
compared to chemistry which is fast at
four per second and so that means that
the unwinding of the DNA is actually
rate limiting and as soon as the DNA is
unwound the chemistry can occur so what
about these high fidelity variants that
exist so we looked at the high fidelity
variants we looked at a hyper caste nine
and we also looked at cast nine hf1 that
have been published in the literature
and so you can see that we looked at
both on target and off target cleavage
and on target it's a perfectly matched
substrate off target it has a three base
pair mismatch at the pam distal end so
at the very end of the duplex away from
the pin and you can see that the both
hyper cast nine and cast nine hf1
dramatically decreased catalytic
activity compared to the wild type
proteins so as opposed to rate of one
per second or at a rate of about 0.03
per second for the proteins with the own
target and then 0.003 per second for
when the protein is cleaving an off
target and so this seems that the major
effect of these high fidelity bearings
is to decrease the speed at which the
target can be cleaved and so to
understand how this works when
to think of it as a kinetic partitioning
so we should also not shown here as we
showed that the early formation rate is
similar between all of these Cassadine
variants in all targets so whether or
not it's a perfect match or off target
and so something else needs to be
happening and so what we did is a
kinetic partitioning experiment so where
we use a competing DNA and so in these
particular experiments we use a
competing on target DNA and you can see
that in the case of the wild-type enzyme
when you have an off target 67% of the
enzyme is still committed to go forward
and cleave the perfect match whereas
when you look at height by cast nine and
cast nine hf1 when you have the off
target and you adding the competing
wild-type perfect match DNA only 24
percent in the hyper case is committed
to going forward whereas 10 percent in
the case of casa h f1 is committed to go
forward and so what this tells us is
that there's a kinetic partitioning
effect that's occurring that's leading
to the observed and increases in
specificity that are seen in vivo and so
a cartoon I think will help us to better
understand this mechanism so now in the
case of these high fidelity variants the
DNA wine is fast so it's still occurring
out about one per second so then we have
our loop created but the irreversible
cleavage reaction that occurs when the
two strings are actually snipped by both
the hmhm of c domains that's happening
very slow for these enzymes which gives
the enzyme a chance to react will break
and in fact eject the DNA so going all
the way back to the DNA being rewound
and then removed from the enzymes so
it's you can think of it a lot like the
enzymes chewing very slowly so
giving himself a chance to taste and see
if it likes it if it doesn't like it
there's plenty of time for it to spit
the DNA substrate back out whereas if it
quickly went through and shooted there's
no chance for it to remove the DNA and
so conclusions and future directions so
from the first part of the talk type for
complexes are minimal and in shrieking
it's tempting that pathi size if they
target RNA based on structural
similarities that they have with the
type 3 complexes second part of the talk
I talked about high fidelity casts nine
variants and how they improve
discrimination via kinetic partitioning
so whether to go for with the
irreversible cleavage or going backwards
and so future directions in the
laboratory include determining how the
type 4 complexes target nucleic acids so
we need to figure out which nucleic acid
that it actually targets and then we
would like to solve structures of the
complex with that particular nucleic
acid and we'd also like to do some HH
labeling experiments that have similar
to those that have been done the da da
lab but with our kinetic scheme so in
the stop flow apparatus so that we can
fit the h and h dynamics into our
overall kinetic model for how the
Cassadine enzyme works the mat I'd like
to thank the people that have already
acknowledged I've done the work and then
my laboratory which is full of some
great graduate students postdocs and
undergraduates I'd like to thank funding
in particular these CRISPR related
studies are funded by the Welch
foundation and the kleeberg foundation
check us out my website at cryo am that
CMS that you texas dot edu and you can
follow me on twitter at David W Taylor
jr. and I'd like to thank you for your
attention
and I'd be happy to take questions I
guess offline Thanks